so I'm in New York City and I'm Dyslexic
dyslexia has a lot to do with the term
decoding if you are a human and you live
in the modern world which is literally
every person watching this video right
now your life is decoding our world is
made up of symbols a bunch of symbols
that don't inherently mean like look at
this symbol this symbol means something
to you only because it's been given
meaning by our society or your culture
your language but what about this symbol
a lot of you have no idea what this
symbol means it doesn't mean anything to
you but to others it does
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy woman it wasn't like a five-dollar
pork bun yeah that's like it's trying to
be - shall we yeah
it's like the real deal all right let's
go eat these I mean your whole school
experience is one giant lesson in
decoding books and symbols and images to
give meaning and knowledge to your brain
if you're dyslexic this whole decoding
thing is hard especially when it gets
really advanced and you have pages and
pages of all of these random symbols and
you're supposed to make meaning out of
them
that's really difficult for someone who
has dyslexia I'm gonna stop using fancy
language here and just say it straight
if you're dyslexic you suck at reading
[Music]
if you look at a page most people are
able to single out these lines and track
along them quickly and seamlessly
decoding the words into Meeny
when I look at a page like this my brain
sees something a little bit more like
this tracking along these lines is just
a really clunky process for me that's a
downer a year ago we were in Hong Kong
for borders birthday and this year we're
in Catalan
and we're just falling in love with this
do you think
[Music]
hello a
so what does this all mean well being a
dyslexic a child you just kind of feel
not very smart at least I didn't
there was always special meetings I had
to have with my teacher and my parents
to like come up with alternative
learning schedules and like big learning
goals and all of these things that
basically made me feel like look you're
not getting this what this did is it
kind of instilled this idea that like
okay I'm not one of the smart kids and
that's okay I actually made peace with
this by the time I was in middle school
you really start to have to read a lot
more and so that's where my mom started
to read to me like these longer books
which was really embarrassing when
you're like an eighth grader and your
mom's reading to you
thank you mom seriously though so sweet
my mother then would go out and find
audiobooks when I was in high school you
know this wasn't like a long time ago
but you know it's in the 2000s when
audio books were on cassettes all this
is to say my mother is lovely and so so
so supportive and wonderful and really
helped me through this and none of us
knew that it was dyslexia like during
this time I just knew it wasn't good at
reading and I wasn't quote very smart so
I made it through high school
didn't get great grades didn't get good
test scores but like made it through
college was my nightmare I mean college
was fun I liked college but for the
reading aspect college was a nightmare
for someone with dyslexia I still don't
know him dyslexic I just know that I
hate reading and in college everything
is about reading you devour these
textbooks you come and discuss what you
read and it's like hundreds of pages of
reading a night that was just never ever
gonna happen to me so this is where I
start to develop creative solutions to
get my way around reading so I start to
record the lectures for my professors
like the classes I would record them and
listen to them over and over again while
I would like go on runs or while I was
like walking up to campus or whatever it
was and this way I was able to let the
content sink in but not have to do the
50 or 60 pages of reading not the best
solution but definitely the only
solution I had at my fingertips to get
through a lot of these heavy
reading classes in college incidentally
I also had an issue with writing because
I didn't do a lot of reading I wasn't a
super good writer I was not a very good
typist couldn't spell super well and so
my second kind of creative solution was
starting to lean into visuals as my way
of presenting things so instead of like
writing a paper for a project I would
say like hey can I like make a video
about it or can I like do like an
infographic or something like that and
on the other side of college what I came
away with is that I could learn I just
wasn't going to do it in the traditional
way that was going to be doing it
through these creative solutions of
finding other alternative ways of
ingesting information and sharing that
information or communicating that
information and then I go into a
neurologist at George Washington Medical
Center in DC and get officially
diagnosed which doesn't mean anything
there's no like medicine or like therapy
for dyslexia what it means though is
that you're suddenly validated in like
okay I'm not just not smart or like I'm
not just not disciplined with books I
actually have something wrong with my
brain and that was incredibly freeing
for me I think her least valid ating
[Music]
it's time for an ADD because well gotta
feed my family somehow right
well you feed our family - together we
will feed our family with Internet ads
I'm gonna tell you the rest of the story
but for this video I reached out
specifically to audible which is a
company that I use and have used for
many years back in like I think it was
you know the early 2010s when I started
to discover audible and that's when I
started to devour devour audiobooks I
started to average 25 books a year which
it was like from a guy who would read
one book a year suddenly I'm reading 25
books a year like this changed my entire
life audible in case you don't know is
this giant repository of audiobooks this
app has been like a integral part of my
world so many books one that I just read
it's about India it's called Midnight's
Furies it is an amazing book I'm just
finishing it now and it has really
informed a lot of my writing and
thinking about India lately very
informative very well-written very
detailed so if you're interested in
audible you can go to this link
audible.com slash Johnny Harris and you
can get a 30-day free trial where you
get a book any book you want for free
and you get two audible originals which
is like content that they've created
themselves that you can pick from like a
big repository the ad is over thank you
for listening I'm now here in lower
Manhattan at the box office we're here
because is is hosting this event for
eater tonight because of her Taiwan
stuff and I'm just +18 I'm just hanging
out I'm gonna finish this story of what
dyslexia looks like when you're in your
20s and now in my early 30s but I have
to go up and say hi to my teammates and
hang out and get some work done but I'll
I'll pick it up in a minute
[Music]
I pulled battery kind of died on the
camera and just like I I just I just got
too busy eating Taiwanese food at that
eater event did great is no serious is
you gonna finish this story about
dyslexia and what that means for me is
like a 31 year old person so let's get
out of here go into the city and
continue the story and bagel is one of
our favorite spots if not our total
favorite spot in the city bagels till
Brooklyn bagel on a tab
lovely okay so we're talking my current
life with dyslexia which is a very
different life than school and
university during school and university
days
dyslexia basically exacerbated the
reality that I was not good at learning
in an informal environment and just made
it drudgery and difficulty all the time
now that I'm in the real world where
reading books and taking tests and
jumping through like formal hoops is not
the measure of success
I find it much much easier to feel like
I'm smart and that I can be successful
taking multiple-choice tests is not the
measure of success in the real world
in my 20s and now into my early 30s I
feel like dyslexia yeah as a big part of
my life and it affects my day to day
experience to some degree meaning when
I'm like looking at a list of things and
I'm supposed to like find a name or a
number or something I like sometimes
literally cannot find it like I cannot
see it even though it's like right there
but it doesn't affect my ability to have
a successful career or to learn things
or to have good relationships or any of
those things that are to me just way
more important than multiple-choice
tests if anything dyslexia and the
experience of having to find creative
solutions to my problems in school has
made me a more resourceful person in the
sense that typical mechanisms for
learning and doing things don't work for
me all the time and so I've gotten used
to and comfortable with finding
alternative solutions usually creative
solutions to make things happen and I
think that's our move with some really
useful tools
when it comes to making videos or
building things or executing or whatever
so if anything I feel like dyslexia
while it is a a mental kind of hindrance
in some ways it also has given me tools
that I'm really grateful for I don't
know what dislikes it feels like for
other people and I'm sure it's not
exactly the same is it what it feels
like for me but I would be really
curious to hear your thoughts on that so
if you are someone who struggles with
dyslexia tell me about it like tell me
what your experience is like because I'm
really interested to hear that
okay we're headed back to DC more
borders ebony and borders coming out
really soon holy smokes is this show
it's coming out thanks for watching
thank you audible for sponsoring this
video and for teaching me how to listen
to books and I'll see you next time
[Music]